geschickt
hallo freunde wir sind gerade in köln
angekommen mit dem auto das sind ich und
denke ich wurde eingeladen von saturn
deswegen seht ihr hier oben auch
irgendwie produktplatzierungen und zwar
den neuen store von denen man zu testen
janson saturn connector aufgebaut
übrigens fand wir haben das fenster auf
damit die belichtung das ist aber es
regnet gerade habe ich mal die
eingeladen den neuen store von denen mal
zu testen weil die da das ist kein
normaler saturn soll sondern die haben
da drohnen vr sachen 3d sachen gemalte
sachen wirklich mega geilen konnten und
das werden wir halt gleich mal austesten
wir sind jetzt gerade auf jeden fall auf
dem weg dahin und werden bald einige
coole sachen ausprobieren
wir sind jetzt im saturn connect in köln
in der schildergasse in der innenstadt
angekommen falls sich die adresse
richtig gesagt habe sönke wird da vorne
gerade gezeichnet und zwar in so einem
tablet-pc ding am computer zeigt vorne
wird hier gerade gezeichnet
jedenfalls werden wir jetzt hier noch
ein bisschen durchlaufen haben
beispielsweise super duper dreh dich
einfach einmal komplett im kreis um das
zu zeigen was hinter der wir hinten
haben wir gaming sachen dabei sind
beispielsweise tastaturen und sondern
verquatscht hier haben wir taschen da
hinten haben wir eine menge menschen die
mich alle komisch angucken weil ich eine
kamera laden erinnert quasi gar nicht
irgendwie satt uhren sondern einfach
viel mehr technik experimentiert
was sagt der kameramann
ich habe mich jetzt gerade auch vor ort
report rät porträtieren lassen richtig
bricht so sieht das jetzt hier aus hier
das bin ich
im unterschied mit ich bin einfach ich
hier vorne haben wir boxen
ganzen tablet-pc von samsung für mich
dann ganz so gut aus wir sind die ganze
smart whatcha say what android wir haben
hier kopfhörer dann haben wir hier noch
sehe ich die ganze bürokratie haben wir
auch noch wachsen und hier haben wir
noch mehr kopfhörer tatsächlich man hat
hier auch die möglichkeit sich selbst in
3d drucken zu lassen wir das sie sind
diese figuren und die sind wirklich so
3d mit hier seiner kamera gezeichnet
worden bzw auf denen man das animiert
und das meiste ist dass die leute von
saturn mich quasi auch dafür eingeplant
haben und ich werde gleich selber auch
so eine figur kriegen nicht in
lebensgroß sondern so eine kleine dies
dann irgendwie
wie gut für design und 20 cm
so wurde jetzt hier in den raum rheine
wird jetzt hier offen gemacht
3d generation
videokamera 270 70 70 kameras
ich werde jetzt hier gescannt von den
seiten hier oben belichtet und sonst
werden hier von überall von allen seiten
der dich abfotografiert und dann als
figur modelliert mal schauen wir dass
wir
und zum kreis auf einmal wir haben jetzt
gerade schon bilder mit dem controller
schon bilder mit einem controller die
scans die gibt es hier vorne zu sehen
trasse ist dass ich sogar wahrscheinlich
hier im saturn connect markt in köln
ausgestellt werde in seiner vitrine das
heißt wenn ihr dann irgendwann
konstatierte dieser tour connect markt
versucht da bin ich finde ich hab da
diese anstehen oder vitrine hallo
roboter
hallo hallo
das hoffe ich
der kennedys der roboter noch ein
bisschen drauf sind jetzt hier beim vr
stand angekommen da haben wir hier so
gewinnen
handys reinpacken und dann letztendlich
nachher hier auf dem bildschirm sehen wo
wir hin schießen
und ich glaube ich kann das nicht
gerade für die wahlchancen
super
der roboter müsste theoretisch fertig
sein
wir sind jetzt werde ich hier im saturn
hier unten ist der laden wir laufen
jetzt hier gerade wie treppen hoch weil
hier oben wird gerade noch nie gebaut
meine ich hier so ein bisschen setze ich
ziemlich diese eingangsbereich da hinten
ist die schildergasse und wir gehen
jetzt hier durch die zügel wieder raus
in die stadt daraa wieder lieber die
idee das ganze war baseman für saturn
ist eine ganz gute sache gewesen weil es
echt super cool reicht von zwei mit dem
kanal verbinden wir haben diese vr
sachen gemacht die sache nicht gut drauf
gedruckt echt super nes in bled ganze
stores ein bisschen anders als normal
eine saturn leben die sonst gibt wo das
ganze so großes mit ganz vielen
produkten jetzt hat er wird speziell
wirklich auf diesen neuen future geek
stuff mega-city in der schildergasse 82
mitten in der kölner innenstadt ich
meine reha weil die adresse und die
beschreibung und das war's dann hier vom
video wenn es euch gefallen hat würde
ich mich über eine bewertung freunde wir
sehen uns dann anders wieder